the Federal Reserve is being pressed by
three proposals to change the way the
central bank operates now one has to do
with congressional oversight of the Fed
call it the audit the second would
require the Fed to adopt and follow a
specific equation in setting money
policy that's let's say that's an
equation alright and the third would
place new limitations on the Federal
Reserve's power to provide liquidity
during a financial crisis it's called
that the less liquid option
all right Federal Reserve governor jay
Powell spoke at Catholic University of
America the Columbus School of Law in
Washington today about these issues
j-pal is now with our chief Washington
correspondent Peter Cook for an
exclusive interview Peter Tim thanks
very much I am joined by governor jay
pal thank you for the time rare
opportunity for us to have a chance to
chat with you I want to ask you first of
all about your speech today you made a
pretty strong argument against audit the
Fed the push that we're seeing right now
in Congress the fact that you're making
this speech at all tells me that you and
your colleagues at the Fed see this as a
real threat right now so I really felt
that I had to speak out I feel very
strongly that the bill is misguided and
and frankly mislabeled it's really not
about a financial audit people hear
about and they think oh sure auditing
the Fed makes a lot of sense in fact is
we are financially audited I would know
that I chair the committee that oversees
the audits this is about a congressional
policy investigation of monetary policy
in real time in a way that is very
likely to interject short term political
considerations into the making of
monetary you think the independence of
the Fed is at stake with this debate
well I would say this is an incursion on
on the part of the Fed that needs to be
independent most of the Fed is just like
any other agency bank regulation doesn't
have any meaningful claim to
independence any different from another
federal agency monetary policy for great
historical reasons has traditionally
been insulated from short-term political
pressures and Congress did that in 1978
and the results have by limiting the GAO
s right to audit monetary policy the
result has been much lower inflation
which has been under control for 30
years to go back on that now given the
country's financial challenges going
forward it just makes no sense at all in
your speech though you did point out
that what the feds been up to the last
couple years
precedented actions the expansion of the
balance sheet to four point five
trillion dollar steps that you and and
others of the Fed have said made a
difference in rescuing the US economy
but at the same time those actions
because they were unprecedented don't
think in and of themselves obligate the
Fed in some way to some sort of review
by Congress or by others these were big
steps so these were unprecedented steps
and we absolutely welcome transparency
with open arms and and accountability as
well I went through in my speech all of
the ways in which we are transparent
about monetary policy we published
statements immediately after the meeting
we published minutes that are highly
detailed after that we you know we the
chair does press conferences should give
speeches I give speeches the other
governors do we testify we talking in
public you know nothing the Fed does it
happens on monetary policy without the
whole world watching so the idea that
there's some secret thing happening is
just it's just false it's in violent
conflict with the facts violent conflict
with the facts right now the facts are a
governor Powell you've got at least
three potential Republican presidential
candidates in the US Senate alone who
support audit the Fed at least the
concept of it are you worried that
politics are running against the Fed
right now so you know I I don't hold
myself out as an expert or a commentator
on politics my approach is really just
to state the facts and let people
understand and the most important thing
they need to understand is that this is
not about an audit everyone who hears
this thinks oh of course the Fed should
be audited this is this is not that at
all and people who are expert in the
area at people who follow this closely
really understand that pretty uniformly
this is about getting Congress into into
the meeting by meeting making of
monetary policy over time we have
learned that when that happens
inevitably elected politicians want more
accommodative policy results in higher
inflation and bad economic outcomes
since the GAO exclusion was enacted in
1978 we've had lower inflation it's been
under control why we would change that
now is a mystery to me are you in chair
Yellen you make a concerted effort
others at the Fed to try and meet with
members of Congress to satisfy their
concerns can you beat this basically so
I speak only for myself and this was my
idea to I put myself forward to do this
because I
I feel really strongly about this and
yes I engage with with elected members
all the time and I quite like doing it
and I did it in my prior lives as an
appointee under President George HW Bush
and I enjoy engaging with members and so
do the other governors of the Fed we're
up there quite a lot it's part of our
accountability and transparent
transparency to Congress we are
accountable we are transparent we
embrace that and so that's part of that
final question that's before I ask you a
little bit about the economy are you
confident if it were to pass in Congress
that President Obama would stand up and
veto this kind of legislation so that's
a great question but it's really not one
for me you know again I don't do the
politics I don't hold myself out as
understanding it I'm just going to
address the merits this is what I do I'm
just going to talk about the facts of
what the bill is the risks the history
and I think it's quite compelling and my
experience is if you put that out there
people of goodwill are going to get it
and they're gonna see that this is this
bill really threatens the performance of
the US economy and will be bad for the
American people let's talk a little bit
about the economy we had a jobs report
on Friday that was pretty good I was
there at the lock up at the Labor
Department how did that report if it did
alter your own view about where the US
economy is right now
so we've actually had a couple of pretty
good years back to back here growth in
2013 and 14 has been two and a half or
three percent job creation has been very
healthy and during that period in fact
last year was the most job creation in
15 years as you probably know and over
the last half of 2014 and into this year
the momentum is clearly clearly built to
the point where we're having job numbers
that were simply unthinkable when I
joined the Fed in 2012 and this last
this last report just kind of had
everything in it you would want it had
higher wages and had people coming back
into the labor force and very good job
creation so it's a great report it's
just one report though so what I'm
looking at is really continued progress
looking at a bunch of different factors
continued progress on getting back to 2%
inflation inflation is too low I want to
see I want to have some reason for
confidence that it's coming back up to
2% and you don't say you don't have that
yet so I think the time is coming but
it's not here I would want to see some
evidence I mean if you look at the
evidence right now is that core
inflation is down the
one's headline inflation is below one
that is a lot because of low oil prices
and the stronger dollar which drives
down import prices those should be
transient and when when the transient
effect wears off we should be back in
the middle one night 1/2 percent for
core inflation I would like to see
something that makes me confident that
we are in fact on a path back to 2%
Larry Summers said in an op-ed today a
message he delivered in Davos as well
the Fed should be sitting on its hands
at this point until it sees the whites
of inflation XY's and there were nowhere
near to that do you subscribe to that
are we looking at a potential liftoff
now further down into 2015 if not 2016
so I did read that piece of course and
again I would just say that what I want
is is data that give me some confidence
that inflation is moving back up towards
the 2% goal in the medium-term patience
in normalizing monetary policy that was
this key line from the statement before
what is your message about patience
right now how patient what can you be at
this point so I think patience is the
appropriate term I think that you know
low inflation through the channels that
I mentioned gives us some time although
it will be transient the effects of the
oil and air will probably be transient
assuming that the prices of oil and the
dollar stabilize and that gives us the
ability to be patient I think that's the
right thing to do it does feel very much
like there's plenty of slack left out
there in the economy
you've got people working part-time for
economic reasons you've got people who
want to come back into the labor force
or not currently in it and most of all
wages wages have been low and they wages
do not suggest any tightness in the
labor market yet so those things tend to
indicate that in fact the natural rate
is pretty low the natural rate of
unemployment might be lower than it's
been estimated to be is that word gonna
pose a communications challenge for you
all at some point you're gonna have to
drop that aren't you if you're gonna
make a move for example in June so you
know what we can do is try to be as
transparent and clear as possible about
the path that path is going to be
heavily data dependent at the end it's
going to be you know about the incoming
data and that's our role and you know I
think we've done pretty well with it in
in the last year or so and I think
that's what we can strive to do that's a
part of it that we control two outside
factors and
if I could first of all the stronger
dollar I know is the Treasury
Department's responsibilities worried
about the dollar but you all have to
factor it in in terms of the economy
overall isn't the stronger dollar having
in effect a tightening of financial
conditions and doing some of the heavy
lifting for you lissa just to echo that
the Fed doesn't is not responsible for
dollar policy as you mentioned that the
Treasury Department really is so we
don't talk about about dollar policy but
you know the dollar is strong in part
because of the strength of the US
economy compared to the rest of the
world so it's a sign of our strength and
the sign of the Fed is is you know
nearing that point at which it would be
appropriate to raise interest rates so
that's good it's a sign of strength
that's a positive thing it's also true
that you know it will weigh a little bit
on our exports and it will certainly in
the short term hold inflation down
through import prices so it might be a
slight headwind but I don't see it I
don't see it stopping the momentum we
really have an economy that's underway
here and sustainable pace you know
printing numbers again that that we
didn't even think about two and a half
years ago final question for them to see
if this is on your radar scanner to the
extent it is and that is what's
happening in Greece right now what
impact would it have on the US economy
if there was a Greek exit from the Euro
and and have you all started to factor
that in at all into your deliberations
so of course we do think about various
things and you know the Greek election
and the events since Greece of course
we're following that carefully and you
know there's lots of discussion of it
publicly markets are reacting and that
kind of thing these are really matters
for Europeans to sort out and as an
American policy maker I would just hope
that they can be sorted out in a way
that is not disruptive to financial
markets in the economy governor jay pal
really appreciate you joining us here on
Bloomberg thanks Peter